we're told to look at the rational
numbers below order them from least to
greatest they really didn't have to tell
us this first sentence i would have
known to look at the rational numbers to
order them from least to greatest well
anyway they tell us one half negative
five three point three zero
twenty one over twelve negative five
point five and two and one eighths so
the easiest way to visualize this might
just be to make a number line that's
long enough that it actually can contain
all of these numbers and then we can
think about how we can compare them
so let me just draw a huge number line
over here
so take up almost the entire screen
i'll stick let's see we have some
negative numbers here we go as low as
negative 5.5 and we have some positive
numbers here looks like we go as high as
3.3
this thing is still a little less than 2
so we go about as high as 3.3 so i can
put well i could safely i think put 0
right here in the middle i could go a
little bit to the right since we have
our negative numbers go more negative so
zero
and let's make this
negative one negative two
negative three negative four
negative five
and well that should be enough negative
five and then in the positive direction
we have one
two
three in the positive direction let's
see if we can plot these
so to start off to start off let's look
at one half
where does one half sit so it sits let
me actually let me make the scale a
little bit a little bit better so this
is one
two
and three and four
all right so let's start with one half
one half is directly in between zero and
one it is half of a whole this right
here would be one whole this would be
one let me label that this over here is
one so one half is directly between zero
and one so one half is going to sit
right over here
so that is
that is let me write that a little bit
bigger you probably have trouble reading
that all right 1
over 2 which is also 0.5
so this is also 0.5 anyway that's where
it sits then we have negative 5
negative 5 well this is negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4
negative 5.
negative 5 sits right over there
and then we have 3.3
positive 3.3 i'll do that in blue
positive 3.3 so this is 1 2 3 and then
we want to do another 0.3 so 0.3 is
about a third of the way a little less
than a third of the way it'd be three
point three three three three three
forever if it was a third of the way so
a third of the way it looks like about
right over here this is three this right
over here would be three 3.3 and let me
label what i'm going to do is i'm going
to label the numbers on the number line
up here so it's 1 2
4. this is 0
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4
negative 5 and so on and so forth and
then we get to 0 which is one of the
numbers that we've already written down
0 is obviously right over there on the
number line so i'll just write this 0 in
orange to make it clear to this 0.
then we have 21 over 12 which is an
improper fraction and to think about
where we should place that on the number
line
to think about where to place it on the
number line let me do this in this blue
color
to think about where to place on the
number line let's change it into a mixed
number makes it a little bit easier to
visualize at least for my brain so 12
goes into 21 well it goes into it one
time 1 times 12 is 12. if you subtract
you get a remainder of well we could
actually we could we could regroup here
or borrow if you don't want to do this
in your head you would get nine but
let's do it let's do this so if we
borrow one from the two the two becomes
a one this becomes eleven or we're
really regrouping a ten anyway eleven
minus two is 9 1 minus 1 is 0. so we
have a remainder of 9. so this thing
written as a mixed number 21 over 12
written as a mixed number is 1
and 9 12. so you get 1 12 12 in there
and then you get 9 12 left over so 1 and
9 12. so we can also write that actually
we could have simplified this right from
the get go because both 21 and 12 are
divisible by are divisible by 3 but now
we could just we could just divide 9 we
can simplify 9 12. divide both the
numerator
and the denominator by three
we then get one and three over four one
and three-fourths and just to make it
clear i could have simplified this right
from the get-go 21 divided by three
is equal to 7 and 12 divided by 3
is equal to 4. so this is the same thing
as 7 4 and if you were to if you were to
divide 4 into 7 4 goes into 7 one time
subtract 1 times 4 is four subtract you
get a remainder of three one and three
fourths so going back to where do we
plot this well it is
it's one and then we have three fourths
we're gonna go three fourths of the way
this is halfway this is one fourth two
two-fourths three-fourths would be right
over there so this is our 21 over 12
which is the same thing as which is the
same thing as seven-fourths which is the
same thing as one and three-fourths
and then we have negative 5.5
negative 5.5 i'll do that in magenta
again running out of colors negative 5.5
well this is negative 5. so negative 5.5
is going to be between negative 5 and
negative 6. so let me add like negative
6 to our number line right here just to
make it clear
so let me go for a little bit further
let's say that this is negative 6
negative 6 and our number line will keep
going to smaller values
scroll to the left a little bit
negative 6. so then if we go to negative
5.5 it's smack dab in between negative 5
and negative 6. so this is negative 5.5
right over there and then finally we
have 2 and 1 8.
i'll do that in i'll do that in orange
again i'll do it in blue
2 and 1 8. so it's 2 and then 1 8.
and so if we want to find the exact
place we could divide this into 8
this would be 4 8 this would be 2 8
and that would be 6 8 and then 1 8 would
sit right over here so that right over
there is 2 and 1 8. so we've actually
plotted as best as we could the exact
locations you didn't have to plot the
exact locations if you're trying to just
order them but it doesn't help it
doesn't hurt to see exactly where they
sit when we order them so now we've
essentially ordered them because we
still stuck them all on this number line
they the order is negative 5.5 is the
smallest then negative 5 then a 0
and then positive 1 half then 21 over 12
then 2 and 1 8 and then 3.3
and we're done